Let's take a look at the next step in searching for a business model,
and that's customer validation.
By now to get to this step
we assumed you believe you have product market fit.
Now, you would say, "Okay, now I can hire people."
"Now I could run my million dollar Google AdWords campaign,"
and we say, "No, not really."
We don't really think you have enough evidence to do so.
We kind of hear you that you believe you do,
so we're going to do this again, but this time try to get orders
or users or both, depending on what your business model said.
Phase 1 is you're going to get ready to sell.
If it's a physical product, you're going to develop sales collateral,
meaning the data sheets and price lists and demos, etc.
If it's a web and mobile product, you're going to try to
acquire and activate customers, and you're going to build a
high fidelity, minimum viable product, which is a fancy word for
your website or mobile app will look like it's almost done,
maybe the help files aren't there, et cetera, and maybe not all the features
but the core features that people will use, and then you get out of the building,
physically or virtually, and you try to get out and sell
and see if you get users or payers or both.
The other thing you'll be doing simultaneously with this
is to develop positioning, which is a fancy word for saying
"Okay, I now have a lot of customer feedback."
"How could I have best described this based on what the customers are actually telling me?"
Because you'll ask "So, I explained it to you like this."
"How could I have said it better?"
And if you actually listen to them they actually would have said,
"Yeah, I ignored the first 7 things you said,
but when you said number 8 that's when I really got interested and excited."
And so you're going to develop both corporate or company
and product positioning, and you're going to do this way before you ever spend money
on external PR agencies by actually listening to your own customers.
And then in Phase 4 you're going to verify or repeat,
and you're going to see if you're ready to start scaling
sales and marketing spending in customer creation,
which is the most expensive part of a startup.
This customer validation stage actually gets you out,
and you pretend you have the world's largest sales force,
and you're ready to go "Okay, I think it's really going to work
because I've tested it in customer discovery."
And most of the time you find out, "Oops, I really didn't quite understand
what those customers were saying."
And instead of being out of business because you spent all your money
on sales force or Google AdWords campaigns
or customer acquisition you now have the cash and time
to simply go back from Phase 4 and go back and pivot
and say, "I clearly didn't understand something about
my customer segment or features or customer needs or how to do customer relationships,"
et cetera, and so customer validation in its detail, again,
has 2 tracks, 1 for physical, 1 for web/mobile.
Get ready to sell.
Sell to early customers who we call early evangelists.
Develop positioning, and again, either pivot or proceed.